if they can take your livelihood and
lock you down and coerce you into taking
a substance that you may not want to
take for whatever private reason you
don't want to take it because you own
your own body it's only a matter of time
before they come for your money now
they're already coming for your money
through inflation right they're coming
for your money through inflation now
during times of economic uncertainty
they like to print more money to
stimulate the economy then that leads to
inflation but we could get to a point
where they say in order to stimulate the
economy you need to spend okay so if you
don't spend 10
of what you have in the bank account in
the next three months that 10 is going
to expire and it expires because it's
central bank digital currency so
everything is far more efficient and if
your money can expire it means that you
cannot build wealth you cannot build
long lasting generational wealth which
means you're obviously going to be a
slave for the rest of your life